first of all nice to see you again
you I've seen you guys more than my
friends which is awesome
what so I just saw you recently at
Sundance there had to have been an
amazing experience because everyone I
spoke to they're like really dug the
movie so looking back on it now what was
it like well I think that people were
surprised because if you look at that
poster it's an unlikely combination of
people right you've got you know these
these these terrific kind of British
actors then you've got the biggest movie
star in the world then you've got that
guy who did that thing with Ricky
Gervais and then you've got Paige this
WVU superstar and it's like what an
unlikely combination of people and I
think people sort of I don't know what
their expectations were but I hope and I
think that we sort of we certainly met
them and I think perhaps we defied them
because the reaction just seemed really
really overwhelming if I was too nervous
to actually watch the movie at Sundance
so I snuck out and left Paige and Dwayne
and the cast watching it they reported
back that it seems to go well yeah yeah
girl learn but that I I was I wasn't
surprised about the reviews I was just
like the surprising thing is just how
many people just loved it like it was it
was scary because you know it's my story
and it's about it there's like a
wrestling side of things to it and stuff
like that I could see that he'd be
nervous because he's written direct
directed it so I mix it and I'm like I
hope people like my story I hope they
don't like it a walkout but like this
isn't that cool yeah right of course
isn't that interesting but like people
just loved it like every single part of
it and and the rate is just so great
like I google it every day like wow like
this is blowin up what a cool accredit
so I watched it again last night and I
mean you've got a bootleg copy already
yes
oh you filmed it on your food is so bad
yes so but I watched again last night
and the thing that I took away I liked
it even more the second time and the
thing that I took away from it was that
you did such a great job peppering these
really funny jokes throughout the entire
film so while you're you know you might
know the story and it has a lot of heart
it's so funny the theatre I saw it with
was just laughing
so talk a little bit about being able to
pepper in those jokes and maybe when you
you know what I mean because it's really
really funny well I never saw it as just
a straight down the line comedy because
I thought there was so much emotion to
Paige's journey her relationship with
her brother having to leave home at such
a young age travel 4,000 miles away
carrying I think the expectations of the
family and her own dreams with her and I
thought there was so much drama in there
that I you know I come from comedy
comedies sort of my default thing but I
didn't want this to be a joke about the
funny I didn't want to mock the world
that she comes from or the or the thing
that she does for a living it's because
the family treated very seriously it's
important and passionate for them and I
wanted to respect that but at the same
time I you know comedies importance I
mean I think sometimes you can go to to
more emotional places and more traumatic
places if you keep people laughing and
entertained you know because that's my
experience of life right you know you
just you having a great day and then and
then you know you get some horrible you
know test results back and you gotta
laugh about it even though you like rid
of all and that was that wasn't even
like words that came out of my parents
Malthe like that's something that they
would say - he just captured them so
perfectly and that delivery for it - was
perfect like when you meet my parents
like my mum will be here this weekend
and I'm my brother and you'll just see
that the accuracy between and he just
captured them wonderfully it was gone I
have a few what's called fun questions
see if you find them fun it will be the
judge exactly
I'm curious what TV show would you love
to guest star on and what TV show would
you love to guest write and direct what
would you like to be on the office it's
not well usually you took your stage
name from or your ring name from charms
and charms eventually religiously watch
the office in this makeup I would like
to write in tonight I feel like to me it
shows that aren't on anymore like I'd
love to have done a an episode of The
Sopranos you know I'd like to have done
one of those meaty kind of gangster II
things with a wire like really get into
the [ __ ] here because if there's one
guy who knows what it's like to be in
the mob that's a hit it's a nerdy
English guy oh yeah well I'm gonna put a
bullet in in your head watch out do you
have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy film
favorite sci-fi or fantasy film blimey
well certainly when I was younger I was
a big Star Wars not when I was you know
when I was in my teens I was the I was
looking to go to for me and I'd still
enjoy it but I'm not quite as you know
evangelical as people are now like it I
see people criticizing you know the new
ones and I just think what do you just
enjoy it you know it's just fun it's
just terrific
the Internet's a great place I do you
have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy film
I'm just trying to think of links I do
actually in 2001 oh don't you think I'm
not that I'm not like that I did like
lunar rings but I don't know the dates
and the times that come with it I'm not
like a dictionary like that uh how about
what films scared you as a kid oh oh
what a several that scared me one of
which was um Texas Chainsaw Massacre
which I shouldn't have been watching and
I was watching it with a bunch of
friends and we were about ten and we've
got some kind of bootleg copy a bit like
you with this film phantom and I had a
trick which would be that so they didn't
realize I was scared I would slide my
glasses down so that everything went
blurry so you see the horror of it but
these faithful I was still watching
anything no mine was first of all the
entity that was a scary movie that was
terrifying my mom that you watched it
thank you and then also this one is
completely it's not a scary movie but I
go scared but the Nutty Professor
because there was a time when they're on
the beach and they were like kissing and
whatever and then she sinks into the
sand and I was terrified and I remember
like running down the stairs being like
mom I don't want apples in my tummy
because I'm gonna get squished into the
sand so there you go you ever
at the answer I was scared by the Nutty
Professor I know that's absolutely a
first yeah but I've also heard some
crazy stuff where you movie that you
would never think that that would be
scary but I already got to go a million
other things for the next time I talked
to you sincerely Congrats on the movie I
really hope it's a huge hit for you guys
well I really presented for thank you so
much
[Music]